mr. Cohen thank you for coming for this
interview and your he this is a man who
works and lives on in New York works on
Wall Street and is very steeped in the
in the world of Wall Street knows what
he's talking about he's written a book
money in power and how Goldman Sachs
came to rule the world extremely well
written and read readable extremely well
researched with more than a hundred
interviews with the top chairmen and
CEOs six of the top chairmen see living
top chairmen and ceos of goldman sachs
plus many many of the sort of lower
players but still important people in
that world and it's it's a very serious
book this is not your Hollywood version
of Wall Street although they're elements
of intrigue that you know could could
form a plot for Hollywood basically
you're going to get all of your you know
details and and some of the drier stuff
that you have to learn to to understand
what Wall Street does nowadays and the
very complicated financial instruments
so what I wanted to ask it's a rather
long book up to 600 pages and enjoyable
reading for me but I was thinking about
sort of the average guy who likes to
watch you know the basketball game on
the weekends or whatever why would he
want to read this very detailed book on
goldman sachs well you know the thing is
if you want to understand the way I
think the world today really works which
is the intersection between Washington
and Wall Street and how power flows back
and forth between those two and the way
sort of 20th century in an early 21st
century America evolved in this country
involved in this country and around the
world and the influence that Wall Street
had both on this country and around the
world it's really one of our you know
great success stories Wall Street
American success stories is Wall Street
we've become
sort of the leading you know maker of
and providing access to people with
capital all around the world and this is
one of our leading exports so if you
want to if you want to truly understand
how all that worked you have to
understand goldman sachs because goldman
sachs has been at the nexus between
power and Washington and Wall Street for
you know a hundred plus years the firm's
142 years giving them the benefit of the
doubt
you know they've been very powerful for
around 100 years and so this tells the
story of how they got so powerful and
the kind of power that they have an
influence that they have and how this
black box that is Goldman Sachs that for
many people it's very mysterious and you
know now is sort of the object of so
much scorn and it really sort of peels
back the onion you know on what Wall
Street and Goldman Sachs is all about
and I think it's done I hope it's done
in a very sort of readable narrative
that will engage readers with characters
that sort of come to life as they make
their way you know through through the
firm yes it certainly does and there's
some real highlights with the one of the
original partners in Goldman Sachs
Sydney Weinberg I thought wasn't it was
an outstanding portrait of him in the
book Henry Paulson boy there's a lot of
stuff in there that I'm sure people
would be amazed to hear about the former
Treasury secretary and Chairman I guess
so one thing though I would say the book
sort of I don't know whether this is a
catchy phrase to try to get people to
buy the book or what but how Goldman
Sachs came to rule the world I'm not
really convinced of that thesis after
reading the book what strikes me is the
world came to rule Goldman Sachs in a
lot of time ways and they almost brought
Sullivan Sachs down at various times I
think that you mentioned during the
panic of 1907 they had troubles they had
troubles serious troubles in the Great
Depression
they had their Penn Central bankruptcy
to contend with which almost brought
them down as I understand it they had
serious troubles in 1994 when interest
rates went up precipitously so it seemed
to me that once you get into your
history of Goldman usus find that hole
Coleman's been batted around the ears
just like the rest of us by the
financial markets in the economy
although they do definitely seem to have
landed on their feet better than an
awful lot of the RET while the rest of
us and most other Wall Street firms so
perhaps that's what you mean but I
wasn't sure I wasn't convinced that you
believe Goldman Sachs rules the world I
mean I think you must I sense that you
realize that there is weakness there -
well first of all love you know
subtitles of books or created for many
different reasons it it is catchy and I
think there is certainly a narrative in
there about how I mean certainly Goldman
Sachs has had the reputation of being
very powerful and the envy of every
other firm on Wall Street I worked on
Wall Street for 17 years and no matter
which firm I worked at we all envied
Goldman Sachs we wanted to be like
Goldman Sachs even though I worked at a
bunch of different firms some of which
were like Goldman some which were not
like old and they all wanted to be like
Goldman because they make so much money
they have this history of people who
their alumni getting important positions
in Washington you mentioned Bob Rubin
and Hank Paulson just two recent
examples there's many others which I
described in the book and so even in
this financial crisis that we've just
come through the 2007-2008 crisis
Goldman was able to see trouble coming
unlike every other firm on Wall Street
and do something about it they made a
big bet against the mortgage market that
paid off in terms of billions of dollars
for Goldman that every other firm did
not see and just pretended didn't exist
and basically all went down the tubes
but I think what you do get out of this
story is how often
found itself in trouble and how skilled
it was of getting out of trouble and so
that was probably you know
don't forget Wall Street has always been
a dangerous place firms have been going
in and out of business their whole you
know for the history of Wall Street most
firms don't make it and most firms
before 1970 when they started going
public and becoming public companies
were small private partnerships that had
limited amounts of capital that you know
they got from their partners and if
something happened their partners were
the ones that suffered the losses up in
to including their entire net worth so
when somebody goofed there was always a
danger on Wall Street that the firm
would go out of business and so what I
show in the first part of the book is
how often goldman sachs found itself in
trouble and how existential that threat
was and how close it came to going out
of business so I think while I mean he
certainly would be hard-pressed to argue
that there's another firm that is as
powerful on Wall Street now is goldman
sachs even with all of its troubles even
with the hearing from the Levin
Commission committee last April the SEC
lawsuit even really with senator Levin's
report which came out last week which
apparently has referred to the Justice
Department a number of Goldman
executives for prosecution for perjury
even with all of that Goldman is still I
think the envy of other of the few
remaining firms that exist on Wall
Street and really other financial
institutions around the world still
envied and admired goldman sachs and
iiii think that how they got to be that
in that position despite all of their
you know existential threats along the
way is really the story of the book and
so while they don't start off ruling the
world i think you know it's pretty safe
to say that even despite the slings and
arrows they've suffered and looking like
st. sebastian at the moment that they
have really risen to the remain at the
top of wall street and so they rule sort
of the world of wall street and and how
they got to that position is really what
this book is all about
okay well that's very convincing and I
can definitely see that I guess what I
was thinking when you talk about ruling
the world is more like political power
and there has been an element of that
with Goldman because of particularly
them very influential Treasury
secretaries over the last couple decades
and even as you mentioned Sydney
Weinberg who you know famously as I
wrote in the book you know took the
subway uptown one day from Wall Street
to Midtown for a meeting to decide who
should be Eisenhower's Treasury
secretary he came up with a name on the
subway that Eisenhower hadn't even heard
of told Eisenhower Eisenhower said
alright you know Sydney if you say yes
okay we'll do it and and that was the
guy who became the Treasury secretary so
they've been behind the scenes very
powerful for a long time I think
ironically as a result of you know
Paulson being the Treasury secretary and
all the trouble that Goldman has found
itself in politically and from a public
relations point of view it's unlikely
that the current CEO of goldman sachs
lloyd blankfein is you know gonna get
the call from president obama to be the
Treasury secretary so so they've had an
incredible amount of power on Wall
Street and in Washington and in frankly
the rest of the world and governments
around the world for about a hundred
years and as a result of this crisis I
think maybe the spigot has been turned
off a little bit although they still
have the head of the commodities future
Trading Commission was a former Goldman
partner and then a Deputy Secretary of
State is a former Goldman partner the
head of the World Bank is a former
Goldman partner and the head of the guy
who's about to Mario Draghi who's
considered to be the leading candidate
to take over the European Union you know
it's also a former Goldman partner so
they're around don't don't you know they
seem to be everywhere
don't don't fall asleep at the switch
here it's just that the chances of them
being Treasury secretary anytime soon is
unlikely well what are the things that
you point out in your book and and it
doesn't seem to be as much the case with
other Wall Street firms although you're
a better judge of that is how the
Goldman people seem interested in
politics
interested
getting involved because that isn't
always the case with you know wealthy
individuals so many of them want to stay
away from Washington where the taxes and
the regulation get made and so what is
the I I gathered when I was reading the
book that that was Sidney Wyden Berg
essentially started that tradition of
the interest he took an intense interest
in political affairs it seems he was
also tended to be more of a Democrat
than a Republican although he worked
with as you mentioned with Eisenhower
and other Republicans after a while he
became sort of ecumenical you know if
there's a chance to be close to the
president he didn't really care who what
political party the president had and he
advised every president from Roosevelt
who he had known when he was governor of
New York to Johnson when you know until
it Sidney Weinberg died but you know
there are a couple of things going on
here first of all Wall Street executives
once that's you know one of the nice
sort of reasons I like the title of the
book is because once people on Wall
Street have money then they tend to want
power and there's been a long tradition
of Wall Street executives going to
Washington and not just the goldman
sachs over people with names like you
know Dylan and Harriman and Bush have
been going you know from Wall Street to
Washington for a long time at Goldman
Sachs there's a slightly different twist
on it and why it's been more prevalent
with them first of all you're right
Sydney Weinberg had this long history of
being advising presidents and then
taking leaves of absence from Goldman
Sachs
during World War two to lead up the War
Powers Board and B be a very important
person in sort of taking the us's
industrial power and turning it towards
the war effort and finding people to
fill those jobs he became known as the
Body Snatcher because he would go to all
his clients and insist that they come to
Washington to help with the war effort
so that had been going on a long time
even before Sidney Weinberg though Henry
Goldman who was the son of Marcus
Goldman the the founder of the firm had
a very important and prominent
role in the creation of the Federal
Reserve System the Federal Reserve
banking system when went after the panic
of 1907 they decided to create the
Federal Reserve System the couple of
cabinet secretaries came up to New York
to interview and recap Goldman to see
get his intake on his input on what the
Federal Reserve System should look like
and yeah I felt like in reading the
transcripts of those hearings that it
could have been you know Lloyd Blankfein
talking to Andrew Paulson as opposed to
Andrew Goldman talking to two cabinet
secretaries you know in in the early
1900's his prescription for what the New
York Federal Reserve should look like
which was be the most powerful member of
the Federal Reserve banking system as
well as how banks were to get access to
the Federal Reserve Bank if they needed
funds if they were in a crisis situation
it was played out exactly a hundred
years later and Goldman was the
beneficiary of that goldman sachs was so
it was is eerie how long goldman has had
an influence in in washington and where
this all began it really began with
Henry Goldman but then you know after a
Sidney Weinberg basically every leader
of the firm was either interested in
politics or came to Washington in power
part of the reason is because Goldman
has now especially very much an up and
out mentality once you have made your
pile of cash at goldman sachs as a
partner you know they sort of force you
out which is very interesting other
firms you know they're not set up like
that when I worked at Lazard frères
rinsed ins people like Felix Roatan and
Steve Rattner wanted to be Treasury
secretary they never got there but Felix
ended up being ambassador to France and
Steve Rattner was the car czar but you
know there was this mentality that yes
public service was important but but you
know until we get sort of tapped on the
shoulder for the right job we don't want
to leave all the millions that we'd have
to give up being it Lazard but at
Goldman they force people out so you get
your time in the Sun you make your pile
and then you get shown the door more or
less
either you made into a limited partner
or actually you know relieved of your
duties and so a lot of people who are
quite young and energetic you know maybe
in their late 40s early 50s
give something back so what better way
to do that than to come to Washington
especially if President Clinton or
President Bush is gonna tap you on the
shoulder and say you know will you be my
Treasury secretary so that you know
there's a long tradition of that at
Goldman and you know again unfortunately
I think there's now a chill of people of
having people of Goldman coming to
Washington because of all the political
hay that was made you know in the last
few years well that's a very good point
I mean I think most people they look at
the history would conclude that
Washington has benefited a great deal
from Goldman's expertise and these
financial matters in helping to
structure the the the regulations and
the in the various institutions that
that prop up the Wall Street in the
banking industry the Fed and the SEC and
so on they've had a very big role I mean
all Wall Street firms I mean this is
sort of ironic I mean you're seeing it
again in the wake of dodd-frank I mean
Wall Street has always had a big role
and a big influence in setting up the
the agencies that are responsible for
regulating it it's a symbiotic
relationship some people call it a
revolving door often people go from the
SEC to Wall Street or Wall Street to the
SEC or New York Fed and New York I mean
the head of the New York Fed now is a
former Goldman partner so what one thing
you know everybody thinks that Tim
Geithner went from the New York Fed to
the Treasury secretary worked at Goldman
but he never did he was sort of an
acolyte of Bob Rubin and Larry Summers
and so he sort of gets swept up into
that but it's you know that's why Wall
Street and the Goldman has always played
so close to the edge they know exactly
what the regulations are you know
exactly where the lines are drawn most
of the time they stay just on the other
side of it
sometimes they cross that line and get
into trouble but you know this has been
going on you know for a very long time
and Goldman is just because they
so many lawyers they have so many
lobbyists they are just expert players
in this particular activity and we can't
pretend that it's not the case you know
even the regulations that still need to
be written with dodd-frank are being
heavily influenced while we're sitting
here having this conversation you know
down the street over at the SEC the
Goldman lobbyists and Morgan Stanley
lobbyists are sitting there right now
with the SEC regulators to try to figure
out what the new regulations governing
Wall Street should be all about yes it
seems like Washington has suffered
increasingly from not being having the
expertise on these very complicated
financial products that the people on
Wall Street do so the regulator's often
are beholden essentially to the banks to
explain and you know help essentially
help regulate these these instruments so
there's a big discussion going on now
about the at the Commodity Futures
Commission over various kinds of
derivative instruments that we were used
in kind of central in the financial
crisis that we just went through and
clearly Wall Street's going to have a
big say in what happens there well the
it's it's interesting that you you
mentioned the the Nexus which is really
the critical issue with Goldman the
nexus between Washington and Wall Street
and they seem to have mastered you know
the art of going between the two and
making the maximum sort of profit from
being able to maneuver in both worlds of
Washington and in Wall Street but I was
a little disappointed that there wasn't
more of the sort of behind-the-scenes
juicy stuff about what went in although
I will say that there was a scene where
you which you account about how Rubin
the who eventually became President
Clinton's Treasury secretary essentially
interviewed Clinton when he was still
just governor of Arkansas and can
during a run for president and
essentially sort of endorsed him so
almost like he was selecting Clinton as
the potential candidate is that
something that you can talk about a
little bit more well I mean we've we've
evolved first of all to your point about
sort of why not more behind the scenes
political stuff you know I want to want
to be clear this is a book about Goldman
Sachs so once they you know the player
involved say Bob Rubin you know did
interview Clinton down in Little Rock
sort of blessed him and had fundraisers
for him and things like that once Bob
Rubin left the stage of Goldman Sachs
and became national economic head of the
National Economic Council in January of
1993 basically that was the end of Bob
Rubin in my book so you know because I
had to keep going on my narrative focus
was who was left behind at Goldman and
what they did what they had to sort of
clean up the mess that Bob Rubin had
left behind and and that became the
story of what happened in 93 and 94 at
the firm when they almost went out of
business but so I try to tell a few
vignettes about what got people like Bob
Rubin or John Whitehead or Steve
Friedman or Hank Paulson interested in
politics and why you know when they got
the call I tell a great story about how
you know Steve Friedman who was Bob
Rubens Co Senior Partner of Goldman
Sachs and then was left alone by Rubin
when he Rubin went to Washington and
then you know eight years later
ironically Steve Rubin got offered the
same I mean Steve Friedman got offered
the same job in the White House that Bob
Rubin had had a National Economic
Council and how Bush calls him up and
insists that he come do this job and he
and he tells Bush look I've got you know
a heart arrhythmia I've got physical
ailments I can't don't know that I can
do this that kind of pressure is not
gonna be good for me physically and Bush
says hey Steve my father had a heart
arrhythmia you know President Bush the
first president Bush he was in World War
two you can come and have with your
heart arrhythmia and come and be in work
in the White House and you know what
could he say and that's exactly what he
did so
you know yes I mean a whole nother book
could have been written and and probably
has been written about vignettes of what
Ruben did in Washington or Friedman did
in Washington or Paulson Paulson's own
book gets into that I wanted to stick do
you know I you as you point out this is
a long enough book as it is if I had
delved into you know policies that Ruben
had pursued in Washington that may or
may not have benefited Goldman Sachs or
Paulson you know people have already
written the story of what Paulson did
you know in in in the Treasury during
the bailout and what he may or may not
have benefited goldman sachs i was
mostly interested in how these guys
would evolve in their positions at
goldman sachs to the point where they
were willing to leave what has got to be
seen as like the Holy Grail on Wall
Street being head of Goldman Sachs and
we're willing to leave to go to
Washington and and yes it is
you know we've evolved to such an
interesting point in early 21st century
America where people like Bill Clinton
before they could be considered
legitimate serious candidates had to get
the approval of people like Bob Rubin so
the people who run Wall Street are sort
of anoint these candidates I assure you
you know nobody's gonna take Donald
Trump seriously for a while as a
presidential candidate if they ever do
until you know people on Wall Street
start taking him seriously too and I
don't see that happening anytime soon
so that might doom you know maybe Donald
Trump would be doomed anyway given his
you know silly candidacy if even it is
one but we've just come to an
intersection at this point in the early
21st century America where Wall Street
has a huge influence on who becomes
president United States is that just
strictly because of the money and that
they that they have you know to finance
the campaign's or what how would you
what what would you ascribe that to well
part part of it is you know you cannot
have capitalism as you know is basically
everyone practices around the world
without capital and Wall Street is the
capital cartel I mean the Wall Street
firms the few
Wall Street firms that are left control
capital and the capital flows in much
the same way OPEC controls the flow of
oil there's not a whole lot of
difference so you know the the engine of
capitalism is Wall Street the you know
the the left ventricle of capitalism is
Wall Street so that's why both the end
of the Bush administration in the being
the Obama administration were so focused
on reestablishing the status quo on Wall
Street in in the wake of this crisis I
mean another another government might
have taken the whole approach that you
know Wall Street is bankrupt the whole
Wall Street system is corrupt let's just
junk it let's just let it collapse of
its own weight and something else will
evolve out of the ashes of that like a
phoenix will rise up but that's not the
approach they took I thought maybe that
might happen I mean maybe that was naive
but seem to be a lot of public sentiment
to do that it was it was it was seemed
like it could happen and and you know
don't forget when first Paulson asked
for the tarp to be approved Congress
voted it down market fell seven hundred
points at the end of September and then
it wasn't until the beginning on October
2008 that the second tarp plan got
proposed and got approved you know there
was a moment there where it really could
have gone a different direction but it's
you know it's so powerful and so
important to the way our country
functions and the way hopefully you know
jobs jobs are created and capital gets
allocated and you know you know without
the proper allocation of capital from
savers to investors you know you can't
have new plant and equipment you can't
have new businesses grow and prosper so
you know since that is the engine room
of capitalism you've got to restore it
and that's what they chose to do well
that's a very eloquent statement of
exactly what happened over the last
several years which continues to
reverberate and be an issue politically
and there whereas Wall Street Main
Street has been basically kept out of
the fun reestablishing the status quo on
Wall Street and in the last year I I
note with interest that 150 billion
dollars do
million dollars of bonuses were paid out
to Wall Street in 2010
you know Wall Street is I mean Main
Street is correct in saying and you know
what about us I mean we bailed out Wall
Street they're now getting the benefit
of that bailout and in in their
pocketbooks and and Main Street is still
hurting it's a serious problem that's
why frankly if you're going back to your
first question why I think you know
people do need to read this book even
though you know some of the concepts are
complicated although I'm very careful to
try to explain them when they do get a
little complicated
but the narrative of understanding what
is this firm what's it all about why are
they so powerful why are they worth
saving when people on Main Street are
sort of not worth saving I mean what's
what's going on there why have these
guys gotten you know all the cake and I
just get the crumbs I it was a mystery
to me that I wanted to try to solve just
like in the last book about bear stearns
house of cards it was a mystery to me
how bear stearns could have collapsed
that I wanted so quickly that I wanted
to try to understand and that's why I
wrote that book here I wonder Stan why
is it the goldman sachs gets the benefit
of this bailout how were they able to
see around the corner and bet against
the mortgage market and benefit
themselves perhaps at the expense of
their clients and and what about Main
Street what's happened to everybody on
Main Street in the wake of all of this
and why have these guys been anointed
while everybody else apparently still
has to suffer well that's a you know
interesting point because I think if you
do read the book you may still kind of
question that in the sense that I mean I
think as you're saying maybe people
realize that you can't do without Wall
Street or something like that but you
happen to be able to allocate capital
around the world when it's needed
especially in a capitalism capitalistic
system
I mean basically sort of central
allocation of capital is clearly
discredited in this country but
basically around the world capitalism as
a concept has taken root you know around
the world and very successfully so this
is really gets to the core of one of our
most sensitive and important political
issues in this decade of the nexus
between walls
jintan in wall street we're going to be
taking a break right now and we'll get
back to some of the particulars in the
book afterwards thank you so Goldman
Sachs without question is one of it
remains one of the most powerful
investment banks in the world other
investment makes me also try to claim
the title and one of those is JPMorgan
which really is remains a powerhouse I
believe that was the JPMorgan was the
one bank that was singled out as the as
the not needing a bailout perhaps I
believe it was Bernanke who said Fed
Chairman Bernanke that even Goldman
Sachs would have gone down the drain
without the bailout in the fall of 2008
and there was only one bank that
probably could have survived on its own
I believe he was referring to JPMorgan
can you talk a little bit about that
because we don't want to create the
impression that Goldman Sachs is the
only one with power and and influence
well clearly the folks at JPMorgan Chase
would like would argue that they are us
as strong if not stronger than Goldman
Sachs I think you need to make a
distinction yeah if I can you know
JPMorgan is a depository institution
it's a commercial bank with a large
investment banking component to it it's
a bank holding company you know before
March of 2008 when the Fed and the
Treasury decided to step in and save
Bear Stearns the government had never
bothered to come in and try to save a
securities firm as opposed to a bank
holding company or a commercial bank
securities firms don't have depositors
who can go to the ATM there's no goldman
sachs ATM there was no bear stearns ATM
they financed themselves in the public
markets or by various other means of
borrowing money from banks or insurance
companies and then they took that money
and then they invested it or they they
made proprietary trades or they used it
to underwrite securities or whatever
they did they use that capital until
March of 2008 no no securities firm had
ever been rescued the Treasury made the
decision in March of 2008 to save Bear
Stearns and you can debate that decision
all along I think probably now that was
a mistake even though I can understand
why the decision was made at the time so
basically what came out of this crisis
though it was JPMorgan that step forward
and well did you get the the the
Bernanke and Paulson and Geithner you
know may encourage JPMorgan Chase to buy
Bear Stearns at a rock-bottom price that
deal actually fell apart until the feds
stepped in to buy 30 billion dollars of
the assets that JPMorgan Chase didn't
want so there's no question the Fed
facilitated that they had their good
reasons for that
I suppose that that was something that
they thought they needed to do to try to
you know put their finger in the dike of
what was about to be a you know a
tsunami and that worked you know for a
little while until we got to September
of 2008 when basically you know the
water crashed over the walls and and it
was clear at September of 2008 I eat six
months later that the whole structure of
Wall Street ie securities firms that
financed themselves in the short-term
markets and then Len long borrow short
and Len long that whole model was
bankrupt that whole model was no longer
functioning it's one of those things
that is sort of like a light switch it
worked for a long time and you flipped
the switch and basically it stopped
working now that's a matter of
confidence that's a matter of
counterparties wanting to do business
with these firms it's a matter of credit
quality basically the whole thing fell
apart in September 22nd 2008 Goldman
Sachs and Morgan Stanley were allowed to
become bank holding companies by the Fed
making them very much like the JPMorgan
Chase's of the world the Wells Fargo's
the Bank of America
you know interestingly they did not
allow Lehman Brothers to become a bank
holding company Lehman Brothers had
asked to do that they denied that
opportunity for them just like the Fed
had denied Bear Stearns access to the
Fed window in March of 2008 in the
beginning of 2008 when they asked for
that and they made that a ability of a
loud bang or the securities firms to hit
the Fed window the same day that Bear
Stearns was allowed to fail so the Fed
was making very important decisions
along the way to who to save and who not
to save but you know for JP JP Morgan
Chase was a totally different funded
itself in a totally different way than
Goldman Sachs and Morgan Stanley now
they fund themselves in a similar way
although not only does JPMorgan Chase
have access to the Fed window but it
also has its depositors you know money
that it uses it basically gets for free
because we all know what the interest
rate is on our savings accounts or our
checking accounts virtually nothing so
they get that money for free and then
they can lend that out you know for
higher interest rates so they they're
just playing an arbitrage game so yes
JPMorgan Chase was probably the only
institution that was strong enough to
have weathered this crisis they had done
a few things right they basically got
out of the business of underwriting
mortgage-backed securities sooner than
others but you know they had a lot of
risk in their balance sheet but they had
a very different funding model so they
weren't nearly as susceptible to the
whims of the overnight financing market
as Goldman Sachs and Morgan Stanley and
Lehman Brothers and Merrill Lynch which
had a different funding model now it's
all the same so you know I think that
you also have to look at the fact that
you know JP Morgan Chase is a mongrel
firm it's been you know you know I don't
know how many I've lost count of the
number of mergers but 10 or 15 or 20
mergers over the years I mean the old JP
Morgan & Company looked a lot like
Goldman Sachs did you know in its day I
mean he it was he was incredibly
powerful as a banker after the panic of
1907 he alone brought the other he
provided the role of like the Fed did in
long-term capital management or
during this crisis when they brought the
wallstreet elders together and decided
to put together a rescue Patrick package
JP Morgan the man did that himself but
we've come a long way from JP Morgan the
man and his his eponymous you know firm
that was named after him to what we have
today it's a very different institution
yes they're very powerful but they do
business in a different way Goldman has
basically stayed you know pure they've
made a few small mergers over the years
and one large one that didn't work out
but they basically have avoided even
though during the crisis the Fed was
trying to get Goldman to merge with
Wachovia or Citigroup or Merrill or
whoever it was they resisted that and
they stayed stuck to their knitting and
I think that as a result of that you
know they are still very strong as is JP
Morgan they're both very strong but I
still think Goldman is more you envied
feared admired whatever one of those
words do you want to use in ways that
JPMorgan Chase is not and I know I
worked at JPMorgan Chase so I'm familiar
with that firm and you know Goldman
still has a certain cachet that they
that they don't well your book certainly
explains very well the very disciplined
model that Goldman follows and in in
recruiting and hiring the best of the
class and Harvard Business School and
other top schools and I guess what
you're one of your points is that this
type you know it's really a meritocracy
very much so and this is a society where
we reward meritocracies but we also envy
the ones that succeed so well like like
Goldman and that seems to be in play to
it today too so your book discusses the
sort of goldman type and i solve various
types one is just your young brilliant
Harvard Business School graduate who who
may be like a math PhD or something and
can do these complicated securities but
there was also the type
of Widney Sidney Weinberg who actually
had a very different background and I
thought you might want to get into you
know the you know unlike you know I
worked at Lazard for six years which you
know was sort of an elite pride now it's
public but for a long time a private
partnership then and I would walk around
the corridors and wonder how I got there
and because you know the instant next to
me were sons and daughters of presidents
of France and sons and daughters of CEOs
of publicly traded companies and you
know then me a kid from Worcester
Massachusetts so that was a firm were
you expected to see pedigreed
individuals goldman sachs
truly was and neither they weren't smart
because they were and they recruited
very smart people it was r2 but at
Goldman it's something else it's it's
it's it's this notion of being team
players being academically gifted being
a achievement-oriented having achieved
greatness at every step of the way and
also being team oriented so you know
somehow your ego stayed in check well
you know enough to help the team so they
love athletes at Goldman and they love
people who are hungry to succeed and so
that was you know very much in the mold
of Sidney Weinberg whose father was a
bootlegger in Brooklyn I think he was
one of 11 or 13 kids and basically after
his eighth grade schooling ended at a
public school in Brooklyn he sort of
decided he had to get a job and made his
way to Wall Street made him made his way
to the tallest building on Wall Street
which happened at that time to be 30
Pine Street which is where Goldman was
what took the elevator to the top and
then went to each business on each floor
until somebody agreed to hire him he got
to like the third floor which is where
Goldman was and he got hired to I think
clean the spittoons and you know be an
errand boy and this is an you know
basically after he was an eighth grader
and he over timing it you know was a man
of I think great character and and
living by his wits
and you know figured out a way to
impress the name partners of the firm
the goldmans and the Sachs's I think you
know he wants he sort of got his big
break when one of the sax brothers asked
him to take a flagpole from lower
Manhattan to his home in in you know by
the Polo Grounds way uptown and in the
hundred and 30th Street or something and
somehow Sidney Weinberg who was a very
elf-like character very short fellow
brought this flagpole up to you know the
senior partners house and they got to
talking and that led him to get a real
job at Goldman Sachs and that sort of
became part of the myth of Mythology of
the firm that they hire people like this
and you know frankly pull themselves up
by their bootstraps in looking you know
and it's not just you know to some
degree it's a myth because there are
plenty of people there I mean Lloyd
Blank find the CEOs sons
sons both work at Goldman and you know
Lloyd had to pull himself up by his
bootstraps but not as kids there are
plenty of people there who have
privileged backgrounds but even the
people who make it to the top look at
Lloyd Blankfein I mean you know he grew
up in the South Bronx he moved to the
East New York part of Brooklyn which is
not the greatest part of town you know
for a better life his father was a
postman Lloyd told me I thought this is
fascinating that his father was then you
know after he retired was replaced by a
machine so you know the job that his
father was doing was outmoded and a
machine could do it could do it better
and his mother worked in an alarm
security company which he described to
me as a growth industry in that part of
Brooklyn and and he went to public high
school and you know with where harvard
happened to recruit found him he was
clearly one of the smartest kids in the
class and gave him a full scholarship to
go to harvard where he found himself
surrounded by like prep school students
and he didn't feel like he fit in but he
eventually did well at harvard then went
to harvard law school and then you know
as he said i went from being a
underprivileged child to a child of
privilege because he had access to
Harvard and Harvard Law School and you
know this is very much the kind of
person that makes it to the top at
Goldman Sachs I mean you know Henry
Paulson grew up on a farm you know 40
miles outside of Chicago and his you
know grandfather had been a leading
watchmaker and businessmen in Chicago
but those businesses failed during the
Depression and as his father was
basically a farmer and and Jon Corzine
who also ran Goldman for a period of
time grew up on a farm in southern
Illinois and this is the kind of person
that that makes it to the top there I
mean we're not talking about sons are
rarely I mean daughters unfortunately
seem don't seem to have much place at
Goldman but son these are not the sons
of privilege this is not primogeniture
here this is real meritocracy and it's
it's an impressive collection of people
you know honestly in reporting this book
and interviewing these people they
exhausted me I mean spending three hours
with Henry Paulson can be exhausting
because he's so much energy even though
you know he came across when his
Treasury secretary is somewhat
inarticulate and people have remarked on
that I found him extremely articulate
and extremely energetic and and charming
incredibly charming and so you know
three hours later with an alpha male
like Hank Paulson I was exhausted I
needed a break I was going to ask you
about Hank Paulson because that was one
hit the portrait of Henry Paulson that
comes out in this book is is one of the
really to me revelatory parts of it
because you show how he started out as
such a straight arrow and was raised up
into the management because he had
honesty forthrightness you know he he
established good relationships with
people he was a patient who's not going
to embarrass the firm and some other
partners had been doing it about the
time that that Hank Paulson was elevated
to the management of the firm maybe I
misread it but I see him as ending up as
kind of a Machiavellian figure who ended
up edging out his Co part chairman Jon
Corzine
and some other people in the quarry that
he pushed out
and almost like a backstabber in that
regard that seemed surprising to me and
he he comes across as an extremely
forceful person which is particularly
interesting for those of us in
Washington who saw him as Treasury
secretary and the key role that he
played throughout the financial crisis
can you talk a little bit more about
this and you know the way he pushed out
Corzine who was also a figure here in
Washington I mean former senator from
New Jersey and Governor of New Jersey
again you're right I mean this was a
revelation to me because my image of
Hank Paulson was the one we all saw on
TV during the crisis the one who got
down on bended knee to ask Nancy Pelosi
for you know seven hundred billion
dollars which was plenty audacious you
have to admit and but I found somebody
who was as I said you know extremely
charming articulate a man of high
integrity now nevertheless and all that
can be true at the same time that he he
was quite ruthless about you know making
sure that I mean he would say of course
that he did it in the interest of what
was he thought was best for Goldman
Sachs
in other words the reason John Corzine
had to be pushed out of Goldman Sachs
was because he Hank Paulson and others
thought that but but particularly Hank
Paulson thought that Corzine was leading
the firm in the wrong direction I tell
the story in the book about how Corzine
was eager to do these mergers with first
with Salomon Brothers then with
travelers and JP Morgan and what the one
that ultimately tripped him up is when
he started merger discussions with
Mellon Bank you know which frankly may
have been a very good fit for Goldman
but basically his other partners didn't
want him to do that and he didn't inform
them and so Paulson and others thought
that Corzine was just leading the firm
in the wrong direction so then you know
you know I'm sure he would say in all
humility I mean I was just doing what my
partners wanted me to do or what I
thought was the best for Goldman Sachs
but it does come off very Machiavellian
and he basically got rid of being
completely kneecap
jon corzine jon corzine never saw it
coming and before we knew it right on
the verse of the IPO in in the spring of
1999 Corzine was out and and Paulson had
used it made alliances with other people
other people in the management team to
become CEO and take the firm public and
he ironically the two guys he told who
who who who became his allies John Thain
who later became CEO of Merrill Lynch
and is now the CEO of CIT and John
Thornton who is now the head of the
Brookings Institute these two guys
formed an alliance with Paulson and with
the understanding that Paulson was gonna
be the CEO for a couple years and then
leave and turn it over to these two guys
well you know Hank being Hank you know
sort of liked the job too much I mean he
was having a great time being CEO
goldman sachs frankly who can blame him
I mean being CEO of a public Oldman
Sachs seems like one of the greatest
jobs in the world especially when you're
not the target of so much higher public
ire as Lloyd Blankfein is at the moment
but you know Hank had the board of
directors in his pocket and they kept
wanting him there so he says to you know
continue to lead the firm so basically
Hank didn't want to leave and that made
Fame and Thorton expendable and he
pushed them out too and and you know you
sort of take that in toto and it does
look very Machiavellian and so you know
on the one hand you've got this guy
who's very charming and personable and
down-to-earth and makes plenty of time
you know for people like me which I
appreciated on the other hand you just
look at what he did and you say you know
this guy does what has to be done even
if he thinks it's in the best history of
interest of goldman sachs to do that now
you know the reason he pushed thin and
thornton aside ultimately is because he
saw this guy Lord blank fine
he saw the direction that the business
was going and the way that Goldman could
make most money which is in the trading
in the proprietary trading business and
he knew that Thain and Thornton didn't
have those skills so they became
expendable and he saw a Lloyd Blankfein
who did he plucked him up out of the the
masses and and and made him the next
leader of the firm
and when he went to Washington his
Treasury secretary it was obvious that
bling fine was going to get the job so
again it looks very ruthless in
Machiavellian a Paulson would say I did
what was in the best interests of
goldman sachs you know what and it's
hard to debate that because if Lloyd
Blankfein hadn't been the CEO of goldman
sachs during the crisis goldman may have
gone down the tubes just like everybody
else and instead it put on this big
short and made this big short against
the mortgage market and did things to
save itself which now don't look so
great either but at least you know they
can make a credible argument that they
you know didn't need the bailout which
is something they've done i think they
probably would have gone down the tubes
and the tsunami just like everybody else
but you know clearly goldman was the
only firm on Wall Street to see the
problem coming in the mortgage market
and doing something about it
and we now know that they did other
things they shouldn't have done which
was to continue to sell mortgage-backed
securities at the same time they had
made a proprietary bet against the
mortgage market and basically their
clients suffered
I think financially as a result of
Goldman's decisions well this is an
issue that you bring to the forefront
and explain very well in the book how
Wall Street came to become a firm like
Goldman Sachs which started out in the
world providing services to clients
helping with mergers helping to issue
first stock issues helping to arrange
loans and and bond issues and so on for
corporations and then somehow somewhere
in the what was at 60 70s 80s this other
function appeared on the scene and has
now won couldn't looks like outgrown the
original service model yes which is that
these companies are now in the business
of just making money for themselves they
call it proprietary trading and it's the
reason that goldman sachs can offer
billions of bonuses and so on for their
partners and their employees each year
and so essentially they've
become their own clients and they're in
the business of making money for
themselves and getting extremely rich
and this puts them at odds with their
clients from time to time which is what
as you say the the issue that became
problematic for Goldman Sachs in this
whole crisis but I guess is an issue for
virtually all the Wall Street firms now
well again it's important to make a
distinction
I mean Goldman has really pushed this to
the edge this behavior they you know
Lazard
for instance where I worked and is now a
public company they're just they just
provide M&A advice and investment
management advice they don't have any
trading they don't make any proprietary
bets Greenhills same thing ever core
basically the same thing so there are
other models out there and there are
those people as getting back to we were
talking about before had that old model
that sort of securities firm model of
the Goldman Lehman Merrill Bear Stearns
where they were taking big risks with
their balance sheet leveraging them way
up and and you know when it all
collapsed caused us to have to bail them
out there are many people who thought
that whole business models had just gone
down the tubes instead of being
reestablished which is what you know the
government ended up doing and they would
have been firms like Lazard and green
hill and Evercore they would have come
up out of that providing you know
services once again to their clients
without this whole trading side of the
balance sheet and which which got
everybody into so much trouble and so
you know Goldman pushed as I say push
this whole proprietary trading business
this whole trading enterprise making
markets for their clients as lloyd
blankfein tried to explain to senator xi
yes
all of that but requires huge amounts of
capital big balance sheet lots of
leverage and lots of risk now Goldman
thinks its thinks of itself as being the
best manager of risk on Wall Street and
they're not wrong they saw the risks
coming in the mortgage market and
uniquely did something about it
everybody else didn't see the risks and
let it take them down Goldman saw
something about it so
the risk and did something about it but
at the same time they've created huge
conflicts for themselves now the other
tenant of their philosophy is they
believe they're great at managing
conflicts whether with their clients or
internally or whatever it is we're in
the business of managing conflicts there
are lots of conflicts and we're in the
business of managing them well I think
that's gotten them into a lot of trouble
and you could see as I write in the book
during this crisis yes they were very
smart about seeing trouble coming in the
mortgage market and then making a big
proprietary bet against the mortgage
market check for Goldman very smart move
and it made them billions of dollars
while it cost everybody else billions of
dollars but they didn't stop
underwriting the mortgage-backed
securities that were causing the
problems why because they saw a way to
continue to make money for another six
months so they kept doing that to me
that's an inherent conflict that is
unmanageable that cannot be managed and
Goldman has proven itself unable to
manage that conflict despite what they
may have told senator Levin at the same
time now this is a very subtle point
that even senator Levin didn't get into
it and but the Financial Crisis Inquiry
Commission did and if people read that
report they will see this describe is
the effect that Goldman's marks the
marks on the Securities that it had in
the market it's low its marks were lower
than every other firm in other words
saying instead of saying these
securities were trading in a hundred
cents or 98 cents Goldman had them
trading at 50 or 60 cents at the same
time that they had this big short on
from which they would benefit with from
lower marks and those marks got
translated into the market because these
are not stocks that are traded on an
exchange where you know the differences
in price or one sixteenth of a dollar or
one sixteenth of a penny or whatever it
is the these are lightly traded
securities that rarely trade don't trade
on exchange trade by appointment so if
Goldman says they're worried 50 Cent's
and Merrill Lynch says they're worth
ninety five cents then they have a
debate but eventually the rest of the
market had to admit that Goldman was
right about these marks so Goldman had
this big short on lower their marks made
a ton of money and then that had the
effect as I described in the Baer book
and in this book of putting Bear Stearns
out of business
putting AIG out of business there are
lots of other reasons they would've gone
out of business anyway but as I say they
exacerbated the decline of all of their
competitors
so if you can imagine goldman put on
this trade in the december of 2006 time
period that made them billions of
dollars at the same time it put all all
their counterparties and competitors out
of business i mean i'm sure they didn't
start out doing that but that was the
effect that this trade had brilliant on
the one hand but ruthless and
devastating on another and cost us you
know all of us taxpayers trillions of
dollars to rectify well a number of
people you have raised a problems with
this proprietary trading thing as you're
saying you look back at it and wonderful
if they wouldn't have been better off
just letting that die letting it
collapse with the quiet in the financial
crisis have we really resolved this
issue as a nation this issue is not
resolved you know the Volcker rule has
supposedly made proprietary trading or
some parts of Petrarca Praia pterri
trading you know unlawful now but you
know goldman makes the argument that
that was actually only a really small
part of our business now in truth the
guys who came up with this idea for the
bet against the mortgage market this
proprietary betrayed in 2006 was three
or four guys on the mortgage desk so
borrow heavily from the famous paulson
yes he was their client and at one point
they were executing trades for him as an
intermediary and then they copied him
and basically didn't want to trade with
him anymore
because they wanted to put the same
trade on themselves so there's an
example of you know taking their clients
good idea you know there's no there's no
market for good idea i mean the market
for good ideas available to everybody
but they obviously were aware because
this is a proprietary idea that their
client had john paulson and they copied
it they decided it was a good idea and
then all of a sudden he wasn't such a
good client of theirs anymore because
they didn't want to do that trade for
him anymore they wanted to do it for
themselves so you know it's this so
complex i mean it raises so many
important moral and ethical questions
about behavior and about what's
important and what we
value as a society I mean if this
behavior isn't illegal maybe it should
be illegal and that's project if you're
isn't illegal maybe it should be illegal
and that's probably what senator 11 is
getting at and when he issued his report
last week and referred the matter
supposedly to the Justice Department for
investigation I think this is what
bothers him and I've talked to senator
Levin about this and I know that he is
extremely troubled about this and yes he
did make a bit of big a bit of a show
last April of of Goldman and Goldman's
team but I think he is on to something
quite real and that it remains
desperately unresolved and and needs to
get resolved before we can figure out
about what we want Wall Street to do we
want Wall Street to serve us we don't
want it to serve itself yes it can do
well by doing well for us ie raising
capital for the rest of the country and
the world that allows companies to
create new jobs and build new plant and
equipment or provide M&A advice on deals
or investment advice to people who want
that those are services we can live with
more like a utility if you will we can
live with those services but when it
when it acts like a casino and starts
making huge proprietary bets for its own
account one way or the other which is
what was happening during this crisis
and it was probably still happening that
is not good and that's the debate we
need to have but unfortunately that's
not the debate we have had no it seems
it's it's quite unresolved and and
taxpayers are still very miffed about
having bailed out firms that were in the
midst of doing that not for the good of
the country in any way so well thank you
very much William Cohan for your
wonderful book and and makes me even
more interested than I started out just
talking with you about it yeah sure
thank you for having me the best of luck
to you too thank you